in true British tradition people came
prepared to queue even knowing they'd be
here for hours didn't stop people
joining in their thousands the end of
the queue moving back and back
by 11 am it had reached the London Eye
joining the line was bryony with her
three-month-old
little Indiana blissfully unaware of the
weight that lay ahead
back at the queue as well I haven't told
any of family or friends because they
all think I'm insane and bringing my
child but I figured it's the once in a
lifetime opportunity and we'll never
have another queen again while we've
been talking you're not the back of the
queue anymore
that's very exciting she's an incredible
woman she'll be oh I'm not even from
here but I just feel like she's had a
profound impact on all of us and
it's part of History
by lunchtime Kofi was keeping count how
many have we got so far
a sign was found for him to wear to
Signal the back of the queue people want
to come and see the cream to show their
last respects they agreed that's why
they are coming up with their numbers
at 2PM the latest to join were at the
Oxo Tower This is the End yes you've got
there you've got there
four-year-old Effie settling in for a
long wait with her mum Effie is Queen
and Princess mad she loves all the
Queen's outfits and how colorful her
hats are and she's been asking a lot to
come and help bury the queen she's water
of crown all day in school she hasn't
took it off
because she's um
expecting the queen and an individuality
in the afternoon sunshine they kept
coming
people wait the back of the queue never
stands still every second brings new
arrivals
by 5 PM the queue stretched almost back
to HMS Belfast but as the first mourners
went in to see the Queen the line moved
forwards bringing those towards the back
a little closer for the sacrifice and
all the work she did even the day before
she left us she ushered in a new prime
minister
um that dedication it's Priceless so a
few minutes a few hours it's worth it
so many are prepared to wait over the
coming days many thousands more will
join the back of the queue Becky Johnson
Sky News Central London